the former ambassador that Paula just
mentioned is scheduled to answer
questions today as part of the Democrats
impeachment inquiry Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with more on that story
Nancy what can you tell us about her
well that former ambassador is marie
ivanovitch she is a 33 year old veteran
of the Foreign Service with a sterling
reputation but she was suddenly recalled
to Washington in May after Rudy Giuliani
complained that she was blocking his
efforts to get ukraine to investigate
the Biden so Democrats want to know if
there was political retribution at play
here her name came up in president
Trump's July 25th phone call with the
president of Ukraine mr. Trump said
Jovanovic was quote bad news and that
she's going to go through some things
one of the great mysteries here on
Capitol Hill is whether she is going to
show up this morning a source close to
her says that she wants to tell her
story but that State Department
officials have been blocked from
attending these depositions so we really
don't know what's gonna happen to Nancy
another witness due to testify next week
is a former member of President Trump's
national security council what do we
know about her her name is Fiona Hill
she is a Russia expert she left the
national security council in July just
before the president's July 25th phone
call and CBS News has learned that she
is expected to say that Rudy Giuliani
and Gordon Sunland who's the US
ambassador to the European Union were
essentially running their own Ukraine
policy avoiding her and the normal
foreign policy channels if you remember
there were text messages showing that
Sandlin pushed for Ukraine to promise
various investigations even as he
insisted there was no quid pro quo for
military aid beyond all of this the
house issued new subpoenas yesterday to
Energy Secretary Rick Perry Democrats
want to know whether he was trying to
change the structure of a Ukrainian
energy company to benefit Associates of
Rudy Giuliani so that name coming up
over and over again in this
investigation again
again Nancy thank you